la suite des défilés de mode pour
terminer ce journal le prêt-à-porter de
l'hiver prochain au carrousel du louvre
après les stars de la profession comme
christian lacroix ou jean paul gaultier
place maintenant aux jeunes créateurs
xavier colombier jean laurent serra ont
assisté au défilé de gilles rozier et de
katusha
gilles rozier premier défi les
applaudissements mérités
soulagement dans les rangs enfin des
vêtements prêt-à-porter loin des rêves
perturbé de quelques créatures anglaise
l'ancien bras droit de jean paul
gaultier vous habille pour l'hiver chez
lui pas de cléopâtre ou de mauvais
remake de l'ange bleu le styliste
parisien elle et ses limites sur
celluloïd et fabrique des vêtements
fini le show chez tati gilles rozier où
il a fait un détour a appris à faire
portable seuls les chapeaux sont folie
le reste eiffage micky heil velours qui
des laves en talons qui s'ouvre sur
roulettes finalement paris a su raison
garder
katusha la sublime barbares parisienne
elle aussi à redonner du sens aux
vêtements en avant toutes mes années
d'expérience auprès des maisons de
couture dans les cages est de savoir par
exemple celle de yves saint laurent ou
l'élégance n'était pas forcément
obligé de passer par l'excentricité
costume blanc issu du monde
veste tout en sagesse mais cole
milliards et katusha où le rêve lointain
le voyage en invitation
le vêtement dans les malles le
maquillage vous leur propre trapèze
velours frappé costume chic veste choc
et oui la princesse africaine et
parisienne
katusha la styliste a appris la leçon
mannequin chez les couturiers
elle était en fait un buvard dix ans
plus tard un talent est en train
d'éclore
santé
à suivre